Salut. Aujourd'hui, je devais tourner chez moi.
Et y'a un bruit pas possible chez moi.
Je suis donc obligé de revenir faire la vidéo au bureau.
Et apparemment y'a du bruit aussi c'est parfait.
Pour bien commencer cette semaine
On va parler de "Comment retenir ses rêves".
Certains d'entre vous pensent sûrement qu'ils ne souviennent pas de ses rêves.
Le matin, ils se réveillent, ils se disent "Bah non, j'ai pas rêvé cette nuit".
Aujourd'hui, à l'aide de toutes les études qui ont été faites
On le sait : on rêve, tous.
La plupart des mammifères également rêvent.
Le problème c'est de se le rappeler le matin.
La première chose c'est de préparer son esprit à rêver.
Du moins à se souvenir.
Juste avant de vous endormir, avant de vous coucher
Vous vous rappelez que vous avez envie de vous rappeler du rêve justement.
Répétez vous en boucle dans votre tête : "Je veux me souvenir de mon rêve"
"Je veux me rappeler de mon rêve"
"Je veux me souvenir de mon rêve demain matin"
C'est quelque chose que vous allez tellement ancrer en vous
Qu'au bout de quelques jours
Quelques semaines pour certains
Vous allez déjà spontanément vous souvenir
Ah je rêvais de quoi ? Ah oui tiens, ça me revient !
Avec cette première étape, vous n'allez pas forcément bien vous rappeler du rêve
Vous allez l'attraper en fait
Avoir quelques images, quelques sensations, quelques mots
peut-être l'action principale
Et ça c'est un bon point de départ
En général on ne se souvient pas très bien des rêves parce que le réveil sonne,
ça nous coupe complètement et on passe tout de suite à autre chose
Mais si on prend un peu plus le temps, on s'en souvient mieux
Lors des réveils naturels qu'on a le matin ou dans la nuit, c'est très frais dans notre esprit,
seulement notre cerveau est configuré pour oublier rapidement le rêve
C'est un processus de protection,
pour qu'on ne confonde pas ce qu'on a rêvé avec la réalité
Je sais pas si ça vous est déjà arrivé,
moi ça m'est arrivé de rêver de quelqu'un que je connais, un ami,
qui me fait plutôt une crasse durant le rêve, et le lendemain je lui en veux un petit peu
Je lui en veux même beaucoup, alors que c'est qu'un rêve
C'est une projection de mon inconscient
Pour les animaux c'est pareil, vous avez peut-être déjà vu un chien rêver
Comme dans tous les rêves il y a une problématique, il y a un enjeu,
si ça se trouve il est en train de courir après un chat
Et le moment où il va ouvrir les yeux, il ne faut pas qu'il pense que c'était vrai
et qu'il se remette à courir et à chercher le chat
C'est pour ça qu'on évacue le rêve.
Vous avez juste quelques secondes pour consolider un petit peu ce souvenir
Donc quand vous vous réveillez, peut-être en pleine nuit ou le matin sans réveil,
N'ouvrez pas directement les yeux, rappelez vous le rêve,
essayez de remonter le plus possible dedans
Essayez de tout revoir, de repasser les scènes
Sans vous rendormir sinon vous allez jubjoter,
et jubjoter ça veut dire que vous allez retourner dans le même rêve
Ce qui peut être cool aussi quand le rêve était bien
La deuxième étape qui paraît la plus simple c'est de noter son rêve, de l'écrire
Alors c'est vrai, et c'est pas tout à fait vrai, parce que vous allez sortir du rêve
Et donc il va un petit peu passer, le mieux c'est vraiment de ressasser tout ça mentalement
et de prendre des éléments clés du rêve pour s'en souvenir lors de votre prochain réveil
ou d'ici 10 minutes quand vous serez un petit peu plus dispo.
Si vous vous êtes entraînés à la technique du palais mental que je vous avais présentée
Elle est dans la playlist de la mémoire
Alors placez-y quelques images clés
Si par exemple mon rêve, c'était.. allez disons un rêve que j'ai fait..
J'ai rêvé que j'étais dans le garage de chez mes parents
en train d'improviser un nouveau texte, alors je ne sais pas pourquoi
Il y avait un grand étendoir à linge et je faisais des blagues dessus
et les quelques personnes qui étaient devant moi étaient mortes de rire
Et quand je me suis réveillé, j'étais pas capable d'analyser si c'était bien ou pas
Mais je me souvenais qu'il fallait que je me rappelle de tout ça
parce qu'il y avait peut-être un potentiel à exploiter
Bon.. en réalité pas du tout, c'était vraiment pourri !
Mais c'est pas le propos !
Pour me souvenir de tout ça, j'ai mis dans une partie de mon palais mental
c'est une partie où j'ai 5 spots, 5 points, où mettre des images
Je me suis rappelé du garage de mes parents,
je me suis rappelé de l'étendoir,
je me suis rappelé de la valise, parce que je faisais aussi des blagues sur ma valise
Je vais même pas vous les faire tellement c'est pourri
C'est même pas des blagues en soi, je vous le dis
J'ai mis comme image aussi la vision de toute ma famille dans le garage en train de me regarder
et j'ai mis aussi l'image d'un théâtre pour me rappeler du propos
Et c'est vrai, j'avais aussi mis l'image de Jean-Marie Bigard
parce qu'il venait, à un moment donné à la fin, pour me dire que c'était bien
Et c'était vraiment nul
Je vous le dis quand même, je faisais par exemple des blagues,
c'est pas vraiment une blague, ne me jugez pas là-dessus !
J'expliquais que quand on se prenait les pieds dans l'étendoir à linge
ça faisait super mal et que c'était terrible
Et après je parlais de ma valise qui m'accompagne toujours en tournée en disant :
"Ben ça c'est ma meilleure amie, etc.
mais des fois elle traîne un peu, parce qu'elle est lourde, elle est trop lourde "
Je sais pas pourquoi j'ai rêvé de ça, sûrement comme je suis en train d'écrire en ce moment
Je dois être un petit peu en stress, et de chercher des idées
Ce qui était ouf c'est que je me suis créé tout ça dans le palais mental
donc c'est ce que je vous recommande de faire pour mieux vous rappeler
Et plus tard, quand je me suis levé sur mon second réveil,
j'ai fait romonter tout ça pour l'écrire justement
J'ai dit "romonter" ?
Je voulais dire "remonter" !
Pour l'écrire noir sur blanc, et avoir une vision globale et m'en rappeler
Et c'est là que j'ai pu analyser réellement le contenu, et que c'était bien perrave !
Ce ne sera donc pas dans le nouveau spectacle ça !
L'importance de placer des images clés dans votre palais mental ou dans un autre système de mémoire
sans même ouvrir les yeux, en restant encore calme, détendu, dans le lit, tranquille
C'est de ne pas faire monter une excitation en vous qui ferait fuir le souvenir du rêve
Et vous permette plus tard, en état d'éveil complet,
de vous rappeler concrètement tout le rêve, ou tous les rêves que vous avez faits
Plus vous allez faire ça, mieux vous allez vous souvenir de vos rêves.
Et se souvenir de ses rêves c'est cool, ça permet d'être plus créatif ensuite,
plus imaginatif,
de mieux se connaître soi-même,
la dernière étape ultime pour faire ces 3 choses là, et même le reste
parce que on s'est aperçu que mieux on se souvenait de ses rêves, plus on devenait calme
parce qu'on comprenait un petit peu comment on marchait inconsciemment
La dernière étape ultime donc, c'est de tenir un journal des rêves
Votre rituel quotidien après  votre réveil sera de noter un maximum d'informations sur les rêves que vous avez fait durant la nuit
Et vous allez pouvoir, en relisant ça, avoir de nouvelles idées,
être plus créatif, plus serein et plus calme pour certains
parce que vous allez comprendre un petit peu quels sont vos problèmes que vous n'osiez peut-être pas vous avouer
Ou vos désirs cachés
Et au final vous allez mieux vous comprendre et mieux explorer votre inconscient
Je vous fait cette vidéo très tôt ce matin parce que ce soir je suis au festival
"Drôles de Zèbres" à Strasbourg
Je joue juste avant YANN STOTZ & CECILE GIROUD
Si jamais vous êtes là-bas et que vous prenez vos places
je ne sais pas si il en reste ou pas
En tout cas, on se verra à la toute fin de soirée avec plaisir !
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé la vidéo jusque là
j'espère que ça vous a plu, n'oubliez pas de laisser un petit pouce en l'air avant de partir
Ça coûte pas grand chose pour vous et c'est important pour nous
On dirait une chanson un petit peu ça
Si vous êtes abonné, n'oubliez pas d'activer la cloche, comme c'est en train d'apparaître là juste en dessous
Et si vous n'êtes pas abonné, vous pouvez le faire en cliquant ici, voilà,
c'est aussi simple que ça
parce que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour depuis le 1er Janvier jusqu'au 31 Décembre
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17h, ciao !
Ils font du bruit dehors..
Et sinon j'avais dit : Ciao !
Ciao !